okay I want to update you about what is
going on with the Donald Trump child
rape accusations yesterday news broke
that there would be a press conference
with the woman claiming that Donald
Trump raped her when she was 13 years
old her new attorney is Lisa bloom and
Lisa bloom announced that there would be
a major major press conference now this
is the plaintiff who was going by the
pseudonym Jane Doe the expectation was
she would appear in public with her
attorney Lisa bloom they would talk
about the allegations they would talk
about everything that is going on quick
reminder this is the entire situation
relating to the parties in 1994 thrown
by billionaire Jeffrey Epstein who has
connections to both Donald Trump and
Bill Clinton uh the allegations are that
at age 13 Jane Doe was raped by Donald
Trump there is a hearing scheduled for
December 16th about this corporate media
basically not covering it so first
things first this is the announcement
that Lisa bloom put out teasing this
press conference saying woman who sued
Donald Trump for child rape will appear
for the first time and speak out with
her new attorney Lisa bloom
unfortunately the press conference was
then canceled and I guess maybe will be
rescheduled although we haven't heard
yet for when here are some tweets from
irin carmon MSNBC and NBC national
reporter saying quoting Lisa bloom we're
going to have to reschedule I apologize
to all of you who came I have nothing
further the press conference is off and
then also saying Jane Doe has received
numerous threats today she has decided
she is too afraid to show her face this
press conference would have actually
been a pretty big deal because number
one it's the final days of this
presidential campaign at this point we
know that the results are going to come
down to few voters in some very specific
toss-up swing states but this also has
legal implications and the
cancellation due to death threats also
has significant implications because the
statute of limitations is actually up on
civil and criminal actions as a general
premise in this case but what jane doe
and her attorney are arguing is that the
statute of limitations should be waived
because there's an ongoing threat to the
life of the plaintiff so for the court
to consider the case they have to be
convinced that the plaintiff Jane Doe
has not come forward already because she
was living in fear of retaliation from
Trump or Epstein the fact that they
cancelled due to threats makes that
easier to believe Pat although of course
the trumpeters are saying they're lying
about the death threats in this this
case goes back 20 years it's not an open
and shut case by any means yeah but when
the right wing says that Hillary Clinton
may face indictment as she's
transitioning to power it's important to
point out that Trump does have a court
date every time that you hear the right
the trumpeters apoplexy and going
completely off the rails about the fact
that at some point soon based on unnamed
sources speaking generally Hillary
Clinton is getting indicted remember
there is a case against Trump University
Donald Trump has been sued many times
and it's not just all but because he
doesn't pay contractors as bad as that
is it includes housing discrimination
and December 16th there is a hearing in
a child rape case against Donald Trump
now the Trump supporters as Pat says
they say it's staged they say that the
allegations are fake the death threats
are non-existent they also think the
polls are fake they think the election
is rigged so basically nothing exists
according to them and uh if if you're
one of the folks I'm not because I
understand this but if you're one of the
folks who says why won't rape victims
come forward sooner so that they're more
credible uh when you hear including what
we know about Trump's own legal counsel
making threats in the past against Trump
accusers it's pretty easy to understand
why you might not see the immediacy that
maybe Trump supporters point to as
something that would it be about
more indicative of truth I get it I
don't know that the Trump stirs get it
and to be perfectly honest Pat I don't
know that this is going to be
rescheduled before the election right
sometimes it just takes one woman or one
person to come forward and that will
inspire a whole slew of people to come
forward after them yeah and that
happened with Bill Cosby it happened
with Roger Ailes with sexual assault I
mean and and those guys weren't up for
reelection or for election of a
candidacy for president it's sort of sad
to me at this point that we still hear
that talking point from those who just
have this general skepticism about
sexual assault allegations when they say
why now why all of a sudden it's
suspicious that all of a sudden all
these women are coming out well not
really as we heard about with the Roger
Ailes case women were very upfront that
for a long time they didn't say anything
because number one they felt that it
would have been very disadvantageous in
terms of how it could further destroy
their careers and therefore livelihood
we've heard from other women who said
you know I just wasn't going to say
anything at all but now that the door
has been opened and the denials have
started it's not the allegations that
are making me want to add my name to the
list it's the denials which I find
completely not credible because of the
experience that I had so uh I wish at
this point in 2016 we weren't still
dealing with if you don't report a
sexual assault immediately it didn't
happen that's so old and tired and
really really disappointing to me but
unfortunately you should look at my
email you should look at the YouTube
comments that we get you should look at
the facebook comments that we get that
fallacious meme is still all too common
gamefly is sort of like Netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4
ps3 wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one monthly fee and if you find
some games you want to keep you can buy
them for a low use price there's never
any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30-day trial at
gamefly offer.com / TDPS the
games are shipped directly to you with
return envelopes included there's no
contracts and you can rent games through
the mobile app get the free 30-day trial
for the david pakman show audience and
support our show by going to gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s